give you strive for a piece fries you
probably don't deserve it or a Nobel
Prize you know we never thought about it
when we were doing the landmine camping
we did that because there were landmines
killing and maiming people decades after
the end of war it was insanity you know
and so we were striving to get a treaty
to ban them I didn't expect that very
quickly when I first agreed to work on
the linman campaign but I thought if we
can even do a little bit to deal with
this issue to help the survivors to
change the conversation isn't that
awesome but I can assure you the Peace
Prize was not in our horizon I've
learned a lot about it obviously since
receiving it but I didn't think about it
ever I only perhaps when Rigoberta
menchú tomb received it from Guatemala
because I know her personally so that
was kind of cool but I didn't sit around
thinking oh someday I want the pea
sprouts and I really think that
organizations or individuals who are
striving in their work for that I find
it appalling you should be doing what
you're doing because of the joy of the
contribution you're making not because
you want a prize
where's my crown you don't miss my tiara